Speaker 1: We had the 4th of July weekend
in the United States, big holiday weekend,
lots of fireworks, which I can really do without
and cookouts and all sorts of different things.
But we also had an unconscionable number of
shootings.
And very often this doesn't get news.
I will sometimes come to you and say, hey,
you know, we had 15 shootings over the weekend
and 70 people died.
And individually, none of these made any headlines.
And part of that fact that that is both evidence
that we are incredibly increasingly desensitized
to the fact that this is just a regular part
of living in the United States.
And also because increasingly shootings don't
make headlines.
It's less present in terms of advocating for
gun safety, regulation and laws, et cetera.
Look at these numbers.
There is a CNN report from last night which
says at least one hundred and fifty people
fatally shot in more than 400 shootings over
the Fourth of July weekend.
These numbers are now out of date.
And I actually went to the gun violence archive,
which you can find at Gun Violence Archive.
Doug and I just started counting.
And as you can see, pages and pages of July
5th shootings.
And with any single one of these, you can
click on it and get more information.
I mean, just randomly, you know, look at this
shooting in South Carolina, Denmark, South
Carolina, where one person was killed, multiple
shootings in Greensboro, North Carolina, with
people injured.
And you just scroll by and the second page,
it's all July 5th shootings.
The third page is all July 5th shootings.
The fourth page is all July 5th shootings.
And you just keep going.
Eventually you get to shootings on July 4th.
But it's just pages and pages and every single
one of these could be a news story.
We're still on July 5th.
One hundred and ninety two people killed in
five hundred and sixty two shootings over
the weekend.
Now, I'm just talking about Saturday, July
3rd, Sunday, July 4th, and Monday, July 5th.
There's already been shootings this morning.
There was one in Atlanta and a couple of others.
If you go back further into Friday, there
were shootings on that day.
Think about these numbers.
Five hundred sixty two shootings on just July
three, four and five and one hundred and ninety
two people killed.
CNN reporting some of the details from from
some of these, at least.
And again, remember, this was from last night.
So these numbers have been updated.
At least one hundred and fifty people were
killed by gun violence in more than 400 shootings
across the country during the Fourth of July
weekend as cities nationwide confront a surge.
In violent crime, the data, which includes
the number of shooting incidents and gun violence
victims nationally over a 72 hour period from
Friday to Sunday is still evolving and will
be updated in New York, where gun violence
has been rising to levels not seen in years.
There were 26 victims from 21 one shootings.
And you can just go and look at whatever city
is interesting to you.
In Chicago, 83 people shot, including 14 killed.
Now, the article accurately points out that
gun violence and violence in general has been
up over the last year.
This is something we've talked about before,
and it's really important not to get sucked
into the disinformation about this.
Republicans who were silent about mass shootings
during the Trump administration, except in
very narrow cases where the identity of either
the shooter or the victim was advantageous
to them politically.
Those people are now saying it's violence
everywhere under Joe Biden.
That's that's really all they care about making
a political point.
My suggestion is to, number one, zoom out
a little bit and understand that over a 20
year period, over a 30 year period, violent
crime in the U.S., generally speaking, is
down.
We have a very specific problem in the United
States.
It's a unique problem globally when it comes
to gun violence.
There is a preponderance of both firearm ownership
as well as availability of firearms in the
United States.
That is not the case in just about any other
developed country.
And in addition to that, there's a cultural
problem that we've talked about.
I don't want to rehash that right now because
what is missing from I hesitate to even call
it an analysis, but what's missing from the
talking points from the right about violent
crime is up in Trump in Biden's America.
A few things are missing from that.
Number one, violent crime was up during 20-20
during the pandemic and Donald Trump was president
at the time.
And then instead of blaming the president,
they were blaming so so-called Democrat mayors
in blue cities.
So No.
One, it's very transparent that no matter
who's in power, they will find Democrats to
blame.
And then the truth is that this is a far more
complicated thing than there is a Democrat
in the White House or a Republican in the
White House.
It's far more complicated than the mayor or
the governor is a Republican or a Democrat.
This relates to economic issues.
This relates to instability more broadly of
our economic system, exacerbated by the pandemic
and what is definitely a case shaped recovery,
where those that have done well have done
really well as we have started to recover
from the pandemic and others have been completely
left behind.
So the point here is not to relitigate every
aspect of so-called violent Democrat cities
which we've debunked, or of the fact that
the crime increases actually started in 2020
when it wasn't Joe Biden that was president,
it was Donald Trump.
It's that you as hopefully a savvy new consumer
news consumer when you hear these talking
points.
Well, my hope is your reaction would not only
be is the talking point accurate or not, but
a slight zoom out where you say, is this even
the right conversation to be having about
this issue?
Because often it's not.
They want us to be having the conversations
that are advantageous to them and they leave
out completely in this case, for example,
the economic conversation, the violence started
going up under Trump in twenty twenty.
It's continued going up under Joe Biden in
some cities in twenty twenty one.
One was a Republican, one a Democrat.
Let's argue about that is what they want when
in reality the conversation we should be having
is a different one.
We'll continue tracking these numbers and
they're very ugly.
But I would love to hear from you about what
else you believe is causing this uptick.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
Remember that we do depend on your support
to fund our program, you can sign up for a
membership today at Join Pakman Dotcom.
I have I had a two actually pretty big vaccine
antivirus run ins during my vacation.
I'm going to talk about them on today's bonus
show.
Pat will tell us what he was up to sign up
right now at join Pakman dot com and you can
use the coupon code indictment.
Twenty one, if you would like, as we I guess
we're sort of celebrating the indictment on
15 felony counts of Donald Trump CFO.
It's starting to all come off the walls and
we'll get to that later.
Join Pakman.
Dotcom is the place where you can sign up